how did you deal with the mobs yeah it
does get pretty crazy in the summer but
you know you just gotta roll he just
rolls that's cool that he rolls yes she
is cool look love droppings I brought
you a bagel with your favorites cream
cheese holy rabies thanks Dad Johnny try
some cream cheese it's awesome oh cool
but I'm a scream cheese intolerant so
polite packs yes of course you are Jenny
can we party plant off for a minute
what are you doing if they find out you
are human they'll go bad pool relax no
one suspects anything the only thing
that looks weird is how much Whispering
you're doing
you will say you are going in the pool
and act excited and then you will say
you hurt your back and you have to leave
oh my back I love you back no no he said
oh my bad
let's do it oh here we go
[Music]
we got you Johnny you're going down oh
yeah we'll see maybe maybe
[Music]
okay calm down with the five chickens
everyone stop the rough housing
foreign
[Music]
oh man I guess the cat wanted to go for
a swimming
[Music]
ah
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
back
[Music]
wow
you look beautiful thanks thanks for the
party oh yeah you like my little touches
[Music]
[Applause]
it's amazing
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
Mavis
I'm crazily scared right now maybe
that's a good thing
[Music]
how could you after I shared my pain
with you but no Dad it was just a kiss
no you're not allowed to kiss Dad I'm
allowed to do things I'm not 83 anymore
I'm allowed to like people or go see the
world again what you thought you you
said you didn't like it maybe I want to
give the village another chance I just
need to learn you know just how to roll
with it like Johnny does no no you can't
go to the Village again maybe you can
make them see that we could be friends
oh that isn't possible you can't be sure
it's all in how you present yourself no
that won't make a difference
that Village doesn't really exist
foreign
[Music]
I thought I found a love when she was
just a fling and then I met a girl felt
a different thing it's like a hit in the
ring like you're pulled by a string
can't breathe like a chicken on a
chicken wing it was a thing called a
thing and I wanted to sing and listen to
the balance of the man named lady looks
in your eyes and a suddenly Springs in
The Lion King
don't ever care
[Music]
you ready to throw down no no I just
came closer to to hear you better oh
come on just give it a try all right
maybe just a little so listen all you
singers from here to Beijing you better
crack the boxer and get ready to clean
cause if life was money you'll be energy
drinking next to a singing
and there was only one lady in the same
for me
[Music]
[Applause]
that we shared
[Music]
better bring your happiness oh
wait and see fellas this kid will be
guzzling Gold Blood in no time
you have arrived at your destination yes
here we are it's the vampire summer camp
I went to as a kid what's a camp fan no
who names their camp Camp man it's cap
windy pakaka
[Music]
thank you
see then these division this is where I
learned to catch mice and shape-shift
and use my incredible powers and
strength it's pretty cool badminton
yes I don't remember this bad minty well
well is this a night how you doing folks
I'm Dana the director we're sure excited
to have you Legends visiting us what can
I do you for well I'm very interested in
sending my grand boy denisovich here oh
this little red-headed non bangy little
guy oh they're in there he's a late
fanger that's why we came here can you
show us some of the drills like where
they catch the mice can do of course now
we call it team housing
[Music]
so they don't have to catch the mice
nope we find this is a good way to build
their confidence
it's right there what other with you
Pokey
ah there it is Denise image where Papa
learned to fly
like Papa
ah yeah we're over here now
had to scale it down insurance
Hokey Pokey see you at the campfire
[Music]
why are we doing this you'd rather be
listening to those putrid new songs what
happened to Michael row your corpse
ashore or old Mick werewolf had an ax
shouldn't be up here Drake who's Ready
To Fly hey
better like a vampire this thing is
rickety maybe you know maybe the kid
isn't supposed to fly right this is how
they learn you throw them and they
figure it out
it's how I was taught
oh ah the back you know pop is right
here if you need it huh I can't watch
this please don't yeah we go
he's still not flying he will
not it'll happen
this is the tall tower that's why it's
good
you should get him he's gonna fall to
his death he's taking his time
frock I did that my first time
he's getting too close to the ground
you know what he's not gonna fly
[Applause]
I told you Papa's always here for you
again again oh dear oh my devil we're
gonna have to report this you mean to
the papers I guess it was pretty cool
but I'm not about getting pressed no sir
I mean the authorities I I can't not
report child endangerment whoa listen to
me that was fun you're singing his child
endangerment should we go down and help
him nope I told him this was nuts he's
on his own we have to call the boy's
mother no that ain't happening his
mother's already Nazi cuckoo I have to
follow protocol
you will not follow protocol I'm a
vampire I can't be hypnotized right now
please don't make me call the police no
one's calling nobody
foreign
no you're the best kid in the world We
Didn't Start the Fire it was the tower
that's a very unsafe Tower your lucky we
don't call the authorities let's go my
hero stop squirmy are you doing this
because this is wrong why doesn't
anybody get that humans don't belong
with monsters
I am not I am holding you hostage and me
and my crew are gonna tear that human
hugging hotel to shreds
really why not keep us why
and what are you gonna do about it
no you know why you don't know keep us
you're just a week
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
what was that Dennis we're
you okay Winnie yes smizing
[Music]
thank you
don't say a word or I'll haunt your
dreams
oh I'm having even more fun now that
you're
curious you all of us together it's
really special me too spider monkey
now are you ready for me to destroy you
in Monster Ball
Paw Patrol bring it on for I am king of
family fun
[Music]
all right who is ready to get pummeled
I gotta warn you I played second team Co
at intramural volleyball at Santa Cruz
sure pal whatever you say everybody just
please watch the hair watch the hair oh
let's go let's do this oh my gosh this
is gonna be so much fun get ready here
comes the pain
[Applause]
oh
Captain Erica you are needed on day next
up bye-bye Dracula
oh baby I got this hey there monsters
we are arriving at our first destination
everyone grab your scuba gear and get
ready to explore the wonders of the sea
especially you Count Dracula
van helsing's beats are controlling the
Giant Octopus thingy if there's one
thing I hate it's an evil DJ
need positive energy
[Music]
get ready for a DJ battle you just carry
all that stuff around with you once the
bar mitzvah DJ always a bar mitzvah DJ
we're gonna use good music to defeat his
evil music what trust me I know the
tunes but you've got the power all right
okay opening song needs to be off the
shizak
vibrations
[Music]
wow I like this one this feels good
[Applause]
whoa this music is too powerful we're
gonna need something even more positive
now track
[Music]
so don't worry
be happy don't worry be happy it has a
nice message
nonsense
[Music]
Johnny we need the most brain dominating
cold caffeinating song in the history of
all the universe
[Music]
come on come on come on come on where is
it where is it
I don't know
there's too many choices
no wait
this is it
yeah
what the
[Music]
that stinks
hey Chinese corny music is defeating the
evil music
[Music]
let's go
[Applause]
[Music]